but anyway uh you know as ironic Yoshi
came and hung out on the Saturday night
yo she does not 8u he does he oh she
does not 8u I would know if yo she hated
you I have you asked him I'm gonna ask
him right now
Oh money he just texts me ironically did
he are you with bubbly I guarantee you
if you get him on the speakerphone
don't even say you're on this podcast
I'm calling how do you feel about Bobby
Lee he's gonna go crazy
watch can't believe I'm setting up my
own friend it's amazing
hey yo she by what I say I had no clue I
don't want this to cost my friendship
with Yoshi yeah yeah it's not you're
gonna have to tell him that I want to
tell you exactly what happened okay okay
number one by the way I got on my
audition at Mad TV like I tried to help
the guy out and we were friends
number one number two I did DVD essay
and they kept saying putting me and
Yoshi and Yoshi in the same category you
know me I got why I'm a husband you know
I mean like I was so I was mean toward
Yoshi on on the podcast in a defensive
way no I was pretty mean but in a joking
way you know I mean like he's not even
in you know whatever and then one day I
was at the Comedy Store and I said hi to
him it was like he saw a ghost like he
saw through me oh no he knew at that
point he you could tell that he hated me
and at that point I'm like hard
listening to those episodes on DVD a si
yes so jovial it was like I know it was
like two seconds of like we're not on
the same level and then UK moved on
I've never stolen a joke from Edwin San
Juan or anybody I've never heard anybody
say that about ever say that now he's
making [ __ ] I'm despicable and now he
also wants me to get beat up and brought
along to death in front of your useless
oh my god I told you dude I'm I'm gonna
have to sit down with the Oceana
he's such a nice guy yeah what we gonna
happen you don't know what we have to do
is weird thing for me it's like wait
he's well actually one of my really good
friends yeah I know that's why I'm
shocked I didn't know this yeah I was
Korean right no ethnically Korean he's
absolutely crazy
yeah but born in Japan and family change
the name to Japanese okay so the Korean
honda k rage doesn't apply it doesn't
apply but um he I didn't even know I I
thought he was mad at me mmm-hmm but now
by listening to him it's worse than I
thought it was like vitriol like pure
hatred it's pure hatred that is not it's
not something I think is fixable
Wow
I think it's fixable all right you know
I think over some kimchi it might work
no no I think that's this I think if you
could set it up okay where Yoshi can do
this podcast and you guys hash it out we
hash it out on the party I also live in
this house and I'm gonna veto that
decision why why didn't you know where
you live he wants you beaten to death
useless it's more it's more idle chatter
what figurative it's my best thing is
figurative also it's out there you're
not gonna live a violent human yeah yeah
yeah yeah used to keep me porn for the
god sake that's a nice gesture it's a
good gesture like years ago years ago
you know Robbie I mean he was in
Lankershim somewhere like 3:00 in the
morning on a street corner I got a bag a
poem for you I would drive there he
would give me a [ __ ] garbage bag full
of porn they say I still have a I could
fill that old [ __ ] counter thing up
with the porn I still have laying around
my yeah nice to give it for like four
freakin he worked that right wait for
like some sir warehouse right yeah I
know he worked for evil angel
ponca yeah yeah but that really gotta
let him know that I've been talking
about him on this podcast before it
comes out well I I want to say this just
on group level you know that I have no
hard feelings toward him I found that
what he said there I I really kind of
want to make amends to him now because
that was like deep it sounds like you
really did hurt him hurt yeah yeah I
[ __ ] him yeah and you know you have to
figure out exactly how you [ __ ] them and
you have to be genuine oh I know I
already [ __ ] said it was that I
[ __ ] was talking she their model on
DVD what happens is when people are
angry they're very specific about that
type with the anger they're holding so
you can't be broke do a broad sorry
sorry for everything he got to be
specific this is what I'm sorry Yoshi
for talking [ __ ] about you on DVD si I
think that you're a very funny guy and I
did had a falling out
he doesn't like him either but it seems
like I thought you know what made me
feel good he hates me as much as he
hates David Cho but that's not what it
sounded like it sounded like he hated
David but he Amy he wants to like oh my
if I died he had a funeral you would
like dance on my grave because body
rolls yeah yeah I mean he hates it your
face the whole time I was like what and
then your brother's like [ __ ] it you
know what I'm glad that that happened I
it really was I'm despicable what else
did he say I know I already know that
one all right in front of your useless
my parents your dad did have yeah yeah
yeah I really clearly less useful than
he was sent me a clip of an episode on
his podcast where he goes into detail
about how much he hates David show and
then the dynamic between each brother in
the family and his mother and how he has
mommy issues
everything Yoshi oh wow wow I think that
there's a very um you know you guys
really made him feel some type of way
yeah well because he really admired
David
before I think any you know he he
probably admired you the same way so he
feels like I mean I [ __ ] with him all
the time so I don't know why I took it
personally from you guys yeah and I
guess I like I [ __ ] with Yoshi all the
time yeah but you [ __ ] with them in
front of them right you don't go yeah on
the side well now I just did I know this
could cause a war I think we're gonna
have to call him as soon as a good
ending but I get yo she I just so you
know I might say that's right no we're
not editing in this part I'm like it's
too good to rectify it we can plug his
podcast what is yeah what's your oh
maybe not I don't know wasn't it called
I was it called yeah sign up - he's a
very talented young very funny stand up
you know it's really young he does yeah
there I say younger than you Bobby kind
of hate will keep you young just rattled
by it how do we move on I know just go
look at me a second sag no I'm fine I'm
gonna sag I caught it angry good he
brought my parents enjoy well I mean you
know in the is useless in the Asian
world what better way to insult somebody
than the parents it does no I wasn't no
I'm sure he might have suspected
something was going on and yeah I really
I almost want to call him back right now
but I go show yeah I gotta tell you
something I call you I call him back
give me so much anxiety Mike yeah yeah
my sweaty it's fine
[Music]